[Music] Human beings flourish
when they have power to direct the
course of their own life.
The best way to have access to that
power is through participation in a
constitutional democracy.
But democracy survives only if its
citizens
know how to participate,
want to participate,
have the skills to participate.
Constitutional democracy is a living
activity, not something simply to learn
about on paper.
This isn't an old-fashioned civics class
where you learn a bunch of information
about things that are distant from your life.
This is about putting yourself, as a
learner, in the position of an
active civic participant who needs to
know what you care about and how things work
in order to shape your own civic journey.
We'll still cover the traditional
disciplinary content: think separation of
powers and checks and balances.
You'll need to learn about rights and
responsibilities, constitutionalism,
the philosophical foundations of democracy,
and the levers of change.
But, we will also ask you to put your
learning into action.
You'll work from your
understanding of yourself,
and your understanding of constitutional
democracy and the American political community,
to develop your own theory of change and
civic action project.
Healthy democracies depend on citizens
loving democracy and having the
knowledge and skills they need
to play their role as civic participants.
You can't sit back in a constitutional democracy.
Your civic actions are just beginning.